hello everyone I had a lot of requests
for this game so here it is this is the
Isle of Man 2017 this is last round and
well unfortunately for how I found her
first four opponents in the Isle of Man
were women and we all know what even
thinks about playing women in open
tournaments but as I said this is the
last round of the tournament she's
playing against former world champion
with one at an island and this is her
time to shine and the world whoever wins
this game gets second place in the
tournament I think well honored was
second in the end but I think she would
also be second if she won this game
right there be a right behind Magnus
Carlsen so let's see this game this is a
this is actually only her second game
she was playing against Vishwanathan
Anand the first game was played in 2013
in Tata Steel tournament and the game
ended in a draw
he had the white pieces I will put this
game in the link the link to this game
in the description below so you can
check it out if you want so let's see
this is their second game and Anand is
white he plays efore and we have E 5 and
Knight to f3 and 90 to f6 - goes for the
Petrov defense she probably thought well
there's no point playing against the
iron for a win so maybe playing a solid
opening with black
I don't know problem may be forcing
Ghana to go for the win and maybe go for
some chances there so we have Knight
captures on d5 d6 Knight to f3 and
Knight captures any for all standard
theory d3 Knight back to a f6 and now d4
we have d5 Bishop to d3 Bishop to e7 and
castles even castles and rook to e1
Bishop to g4 is played Bishop to g5 and
Knight B to d7 and that B to d2 and rook
to e8 displayed and in this position
well you can see it's a pretty
symmetrical position
I don't place C 3 we have c6 still a
symmetrical position only Anand has this
Bishop on b3 and even has the bishop on
e7 but as little as it usually is with
symmetrical positions this always favors
white as he has the second move Queen to
c2 we have 86 kicking the bishop bishop
to f4 and now Knight to h5 attacking
this Bishop on f4 Aaron goes Bishop to
e5 and here Bishop to g5 is played and
okay h3 may be better than this Bishop
to g5 idea was bringing the bishop bad
may back maybe to e6 or even rook to f8
but well even also wants to grab a full
point here so I guess she's also trying
to make something happen
so okay Bishop to g5 and on plays h3 and
she gives up the LightSquared Bishop
Bishop captures on f3 Knight captures on
f3 and we have Bishop to f4 and I'm
offering to exchange bishops but first
time in plays Bishop - h7 would check
and of course you don't want to play
King to f8 you get Queen to a5 and your
king will be stuck on f8 forever
so after this check King to h8 is played
Bishop now Bishop captures on f4 Knight
captures on f4 and now I don't place
Bishop back to f5 and this is a well
with a pretty decent plan I don't is
planning to eliminate this night on b7
and then create an outpost for his
Knight this f3 knight on e5 in this
night will become very strong so we have
Queen to c7 and now Allen captures it
bishop capture 77 Queen captures on d7
and Knight to e5 would attempt on the
Queen Queen to e6 is played and well
what do you play here rook to e3 a nice
rook lift preparing rook 81 doubling up
on the e-file so King to g8 displayed
not allowing any Knight g6 checks in the
future or a knight of seven chicks
rook a to e1 is played and okay
Anand already has a threat here Knight
to d3 for example and after the Queen
moves to defend the rook exchange both
rooks and then capture this night on f4
winning a full piece so Quinta CA
displayed and this is an ins idea a very
a very bold idea if I might say so
he plays Knight captures on f7 he
sacrifices a piece although it's not
really a sacrifice since even we'll have
to give back the piece we have rook
captures any three rook captures only
three and King captures on f7 and we
haven't looked the f3 Allen pins this
knight on f4 and well what does black
play here
well even played King to g8 back but
could she maybe play something like g5
and try and hold on to this position
well actually no if she played the g5
Annan would completely destroy her as
you if you would play Queen to h7 check
you get King to e8 and now rook to e3
will check Knights to e6 here and now a
silent move but a deadly move Queen to
g7 as the knight is pinned the knight
can capture the Queen and black has no
moves if you if you don't defend the
night with your queen well captures
night is coming and if you play
something like Queen to d7 try to
exchange Queens then Queen to f6 another
another silent move but this is crushing
rook captures an e6 is the threat
winning the Queen so after something
like Queen to f7 now row captors and e6
check came to f8 Queen captures on h6
with check King Queen to g7 and our rock
f7 check the Queen is pinned the rock
cannot be captured and the King has to
go to g8 to protect the Queen King g8
and the rook g6 and this one's a queen
game over so after rook f3 even decided
a g5 isn't really working if she played
King back to g8 and we have a rook
captures on f4 and Anand is up a pawn
and the world now even has to play
against the former world champion being
down upon and well this is no no small
task
Queen to e6 and Island immediately goes
for Queen to f5 offering to exchange
Queens
we have rook to e8 as Queen to you one
check doesn't really achieve anything as
well a lot of people say in the comments
so when they hear to e1 check that it
sounds like you von Schuch
but okay rook to e8 and on exchanges
Queens Queen captures rook captures and
okay this is a pretty simple Rock ending
pretty this is a well symmetrical pawn
structure on the Queen side and then and
has a has an extra pawn on the Kings
side this is well you can play this
blindfold I believe King to f1 not
allowing rook to come to you one a five
we have worked to f3 on on this
preparing rook to e3 Twitter exchange
rooks or to win this a nice open e file
rook to g6 and now a four rook to d6
King 3 to bringing the King into the
game rook to the 8th and now King to d3
we have rook to b8 and we have a rook to
f5 this is a very nice move as you'll
see now even placed b5
I don't captures a counter some b5 and
it would be great for even if she could
capture C captures on b5 and well this
this would allow her to create a nice
pass born on the a file but now this
rook I'm f5 is preventing her from
capturing with the b-pawn as with the C
pawn as the D pawn would fall so Brooke
after some b5 has to be played and King
to see two defending the BTO pawn rook
back to b7 now f4 and is starting to
push those King side pawns g4 we have a
four rook to e5 now King f7 now f5
brooked a8 rook to e6 rooked the c8 look
back to e8 rook to e8 and here on place
h4 now we have a three pawn captures on
a three rookie actors and a three and
now another nice move King to be to
preventing any rook ideas from entering
the game through the a file we have
looked back to a 8 and now g5 h captures
H capture some g5 rook to b8 check King
C to rock to h8
now we have looked at east 6 preparing
g6 rock to h5 is played g6 now with
check came to f8 and here aren't played
f 6 and in this position even resign the
game as well you don't really have a
move here
you can't allow Anand to play f7 because
then rook to e8 ends the game
immediately and if you capture G
captures and f6 well you get rook
captures and f6 with check King g7 and
then Rho captures and c6 being up two
pawns in a rock ending this is well she
doesn't want to torture herself against
the former world champion so yeah great
game by Anand and well he really he
really used every resource he had that
subtle nuance of knife captures on f7
was well enough enough for a win it's
just grabbing a pawn but found it was
enough so yeah this is the game I do
hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon